куля ти можна прибрати, а в місцях червоною ти
зараз про гулянки
за вже ти буду важливим натовп різними на
граєте за веденим і предметами он і
може бути безтурботними
я прямую у варшаву rich не торкаються
одиницям може бути боєприпас
помилився. seven і міна снаряд обидва будинки
може статися будь-якою
щоб залишилося трагедій до товаришів нас
обороняється top катайся на веденого
предмета піднімати та обидва перенесення це його
прокачувати з місця на місця закопувати
в землю на магате з його розпорошать і обидва
раз брат і кидати його водою ми кида ти
угодниче обидва розклади ти он ще ближче
правильніше дин зупан через послід
місіс накидки
обидва рожна бачити дереком вгадали тем
шляхом я яким прийшов
що рослих за видами ряд
валянки ви за номером ходи 00 за духом
екстрених ситуаціях
дзвін і 101